cette semaine au grenier à sel nous
invitons l'équipe du film vent du nord
il y aura donc le réalisateur ou aline
matar c'est son premier long métrage
l'avait déjà fait d'autres
courts-métrages
il est tunisien et à étudier en france
et c'est pourquoi dans ce film on a le
parallèle entre deux histoires ouvrière
une histoire ouvrière qui se passe dans
le nord de la france et une histoire qui
se passe dans le sud de la france est le
lien entre les deux celle usines qui
ferment en france pour être délocalisés
en tunisie donc cette même usine va
créer du chômage ou une idée de
reconversion dans le nord de la france
et va créer de l'espoir en tunisie
[Musique]
les avantages de l'auto entrepreneur
sont simplicité de déclarations
comptabilité minimale et un régime
social avantageux moi ce que je veux
c'est développé une gamme de produits en
tout genre à passer l'hiver à vous
monsieur moi je veux pêcheurs et vendre
nos produits pour pêcher on ne peut pas
être auto entrepreneur
nous avons l'équipe du film qui viendra
mardi 3 avril à 20h45 vous retrouver
tout ça sur notre site internet cinéma
grenier à sel point com et pour nos
prochains rendez vous nous avons dans le
cadre des lumières du grenier le film
gladiator que nous comprendrons en
version originale à bientôt